2018 finale avec l'équipe de France
victorieuse il y a eu des émeutes il y a
eu des débordements il y a eu des
incidents il y a eu des arrestations il
y en a eu pour préparer l'émission je
suis retourné voir des articles
supporters français non qu'est-ce que tu
me racontes
mais en fait sont quasiment quand dans
les manifs c'est les Black Blocs dans ce
genre de manifestations publiques et qui
comme elle est les infractions
elles se sont toujours les mêmes bandes
de délin mais qui viennent qui viennent
des banlieues qui viennent des quartiers
c'est qui c'est pas la vérité mais je
sais pas tu le dis j'espère que là tu
plaisantes pas
il faut qu'il faut oser dire les choses
dans la vie il faut oser dire les choses
il faut pas avoir peur
mais demande au point mais demande aux
forces de l'or dans les interpellations
je ne des quartiers mais demande aux
forces de l'or vont te répondre tout ça
c'est connu
alors est-ce qu'on fait un débat
là-dessus on reste dans la darka
tout seul d'abord parce qu'il est pas
d'accord d'accord
il met son talent au service ton pote ou
pas Daniel oui on s'entend très bien
franchement mais c'est un supportable ce
qu'il est non mais on s'entend bien sur
le plan humain
vous me dites ça à chaque fois j'ai vu
la séquence et je regrette de l'avoir
regardé parce que stigmatiser comme il
le fait stigmatiser
toute la séquence comme ça après tu vois
si tu très bien non mais non mais non
je te laisse parler
tout de suite sur tes grands chevaux je
veux vraiment que tu ailles jusqu'au
bout parce qu'il a eu toute une
discussion sur qui est responsable des
violences est-ce que les violences qui
sont commises dans le cadre de match de
football par exemple sont commises par
des des banlieues et des quartiers il a
prononcé le mot banlieue et quartier et
il a lié la délinquance à l'endroit où
on vit c'est à dire qu'il a dit que ce
sont des bandes de jeunes venus des
quartiers et de la banlieue qui
commettent des dégradations qui
commettent des actes de délinquance et
ça Cyril c'est stigmatisé les banlieues
une fois de plus c'est être
réactionnaire et je dénonce ça il y a
plein de choses bien dans la banlieue et
pour une fois Daniel ferait bien de le
reconnaître voilà
qui m'énerve il y a de la banlieue
lui-même c'est un banlieusard évidemment
qui dit qu'il y a plein de choses bien
dans la main il a pas dit écouter la
séquenceur social en banlieue par
exemple donc voilà donc allez-y sur le
fond défendez-le en fait non mais moi je
suis pas l'avocate
sans savoir par exemple explique-moi
hier par exemple qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé en France comment ça hier ce qui
s'est passé en France il y a eu une
merveilleuse fête une communion d'entre
eux entre tout le monde le dit les
policiers le disent les préfectures il y
a eu il y a eu des interpellations bien
entendu mais on attendait on attendait
des actes de délinquance on attend des
guerre civile il y a eu ça c'est très
bien placé globalement malgré un drame
et malgré des incidents voilà il y a eu
quand même un mort
créer un drame je viens de le dire
maintenant il y a eu 10 millions
policiers
il y a eu 10000 policiers qui ont été
mobilisés sans précédent ça veut dire
que aujourd'hui pour la sécurité on est
obligé d'avoir 10000 policiers sur le
territoire il y a eu 260 + 2008
qui ont été tabassés on peut trouver ça
normal
voilà donc je sais pas où est le
problème c'est pas stigmatique il y a
des problèmes en fait et tu sais que
dans les interpellations il y a eu de
l'ultra droite exactement
les gens de devant lui mais les jours de
bas donc Daniel a dit n'importe quoi
mais pas du tout parce que justement
c'est une guerre justement c'est une
guerre identitaire entre d'un côté ce
qui était au Stade de France ceux qui
ont agressé
absolument pas du tout mais si ceux qui
ont agressé justement les Anglais et les
et les Espagnols
ça c'est super grave il y a une sorte de
rupture aujourd'hui donc il y a
évidemment une partie une infime partie
une infirme minorité de gens non de gens
de la délinquance qui vient qui vient
des quartiers
avec moi
attends attends attends parce que là
n'importe quoi c'est mon frère qu'est-ce
qu'il y a que je dis n'importe quoi mais
pourquoi tu dis pourquoi
je fais un test pour savoir si c'était
bien des anglais
c'est moi qui nous dit c'est bon test
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est des Anglais English face
à la sécurité et moi aussi j'étais
là-bas
on était des Anglais je suis désolé on
était on était là-bas il y a des Anglais
excusez-moi c'est pas par les Anglais
[Musique]
moi aussi bien sûr mais le seul plateau
au monde a dit que c'est les anglais
parce qu'on avait
on est le seul plateau monde où il y
avait deux personnes qui étaient
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon maman pas du tout mais on
était qu'est-ce que tu étais où toi ah
ben moi j'étais devant
bougies si je te dis qu'il y avait il a
soufflé sur le gâteau bah c'est qui
était
tout le monde chef est-ce que vous
n'étiez pas tout le monde j'ai parlé des
Anglais what is your name tout ça
est-ce que vous n'étiez pas dans un coin
où les Anglais si je dis que c'est des
anglais c'est des Anglais allez terminer
maintenant c'est mort qui décide ici et
il y a qu'un seul chef c'est Mokhtar
c'est qui
le public a déjà gagné les Anglais les
Anglais c'est ton retourne
sur la prison j'étais contre lui quand
il a fait les propos de la prison là sur
le fait de dire sur le fait de dire que
c'est des mecs qui viennent de banlieue
sur les Champs-Élysées pour pour fêter
et pour [ __ ] un peu le bordel il dit
pas là il dit pas que des conneries et
quand Pierre Rondeau lui rentre dedans
il précise et j'ai jamais vu moi des
gens en Porsche avec des blousons Chanel
en train de [ __ ] le bordel sur les
Champs-Élysées c'est pas les bons c'est
pas les bourgeois du 8e qui foutent le
bordel c'est bien des gens qui viennent
de banlieue il se passe des choses
incroyable en banlieue génial mais c'est
quand même les gens des quartiers
populaires qui viennent sur les champs
il a dit la vérité il a pas menti même
si on veut pas l'entendre il a dit il a
dit quand même une vérité
un type de jeune il y a pas un type de
jeune de bois d'où viennent les
gens non mais pas le mouchoir
attention
au Stade de France de quoi pardon les
Anglais
et tu es prêt ou pas c'est pour ça que
j'étais pas alors voilà on les a vu
merci